okay people who are joining the
livestream this is some meeting about
language development form of language
and we've got a variety of topics this
morning let's start off with typesetting
of around I thought we had talked about
this already recently yes we talked
about this Monday and I just wanted to
show you how it looks in the transition
between using plus minus and using
parentheses with plus minus I say and so
I having working on these and and there
are some arbitrary decisions on when to
perform some of these transitions okay
okay all right so low exponents of 10 oh
that's pretty
yes exactly
yes so some cases here could be
eliminated so in the exponents but then
we may run into errors which are very
small so there's this balance there okay
so let's consider this case the
alternative will be point 1 2 3 4 5 blah
blah blah plus minus point zero zero
zero zero zero whatever now now we've
agreed that we're never going to allow
more than three zeros here is that
correct before we go to this form that
right that's the transition I'm talking
about yes right okay so so in a case
like this I mean again if this went to
point 1 2 3 4 5 then this would go to
the sub parenthesized form whatever
we're calling it by the way I really
don't think that having unequal sight
are those two brackets equal sized at
least that's what is obscure okay so I
might argue by the way that even in this
case that we might try to have similar
smaller parens here even in the case
where we're going to scientific notation
I think it would look better if those
were smaller okay if they matched
essentially the size of the error number
rather than the size of the main number
okay so we're in it the tooltip you're
just making for the sake of of us seeing
it that's not intended to be a tooltip
for users is that correctly exactly yeah
okay um okay so the question that you're
asking is about this case here so I mean
one question is and I don't know what
the literature kind of implies about
this you know whether three zeroes is
the right number or whether two zeroes
is the right number here well if you go
further down I have copied some examples
from the particle data group and they
put lots of sirasa further
yeah there you see putting tons of
zeroes
well that's lifetim the muon it's very
accurately known well they're so proud
of the error being so small that they do
that but then forgot rows number they
even with the same number of digits
they're not doing that right right for
example in this article on the new
measurements of the gravitational
constant they never use plus minus they
always use this parenthesis notation at
the end so I guess it depends very much
on the group of people writing it yeah
well the thing that I'm concerned about
is our users you know for example mean
around won't generate I mean mean around
you'd need to get point zero one there
you would need 10 to the 4 in the first
approximation if I'm not mistaken you'd
need 10 to the 4 data points is that
correct mmm it depends on the values
know what I'm saying with the uniform
distribution right to get point zero 1
if it's 1 plus or minus 0.01 is the mean
then you would expect that you would
need about 10 to the 4 data points and
squared data points is that not correct
if they are about 1 yes and it's hidden
right but so the point that I'm making
is the sort of naturally occurring in
the wild kind of numbers that people are
going to generate they're mostly not
going to in other words if they get a
number that's point zero zero zero zero
zero one error okay if I'm okay
the fractional error is in order to
achieve a fractional error of order you
know 1 over you know avoided 10 to the
minus n you need on the order of N
squared not N squared 10 to the N 10 to
the 10 to that end square 10 to the 2 n
data points if it's a statistical error
I'm just trying to estimate how common
it's going to be for people who are just
you know running code and generating
things to generate very small errors and
I think it's not going to be very common
I think most errors will be quite big
most errors generation in the wild will
be quite big it takes you know a huge
you know precision physics experiment to
generate something which is a small
error I claim can anybody else think of
scenarios where you generate small
errors well anything in which the
relative error is very small
if the number itself is very large we
will switch to scientific notation and
then the error will look small no no no
the error but the error in these first
things in scientific notation right the
number of digits here that are accurate
for something statistically generated
the number of digits that are accurate
won't be that large because you just
don't have that much much data so I'm
saying in order to get 5 digits of
accurate data you would need on the
order of 10 to the 10 data points but
you're thinking about the statistical
case it's not just a measurement of
something physics no but but
measurements and physics again
to get more than like three or four
digits you know you need a precision
physics experiment you know your
everyday average you know random sensor
is probably accurate to two or three
digits all right so so I think that what
we should assume is that the most common
case is two or three digits of accuracy
or maybe up to five digits of accuracy
and none of that is going to cause us
trouble in these things but for yeah I
mean so we the case that you're saying
wherever it was this case here it's
going to be very rare I mean I'm not you
know is it who else can speak to this is
anybody else here who's relevant to this
no is it I hear description of ID so
it's okay well okay okay so my statement
is um visually we should make those
parens smaller here you're asking
whether this breakpoint here is a
reasonable breakpoint I think it is when
do we get into this case we get into
this case because so I claim this case
is a bit silly right I claim that that
that case I see I mean look that case is
not horrifying I mean that case is going
to be very rare in my view yeah so I
guess the question is whether we prefer
to have some slightly we our exponent
sometimes or very small errors that are
a bit more difficult to read I think
it's better to have small errors than
weird exponents mm-hm so perhaps we can
try to avoid exponents which are say
below three yes I agree
where do we avoid exponents in the and
standard machine numbers
well we switch automatically to
scientific notation for exponents C's
six or larger or minus six or smaller
okay well how about doing the same thing
here that we don't that we don't use
that in cases up to five we're never
generating times ten to the you know
we're only generating it ten to the five
ten to the minus five but we're not so
in that case those errors we could get
point okay in the case of ten to the
five right we could get up to five zeros
here right so expanding that would be
too much because we would get like nine
zeros there why would we because it's
ten to minus six so you are talking
about switching to parenthesis notation
but still keeping the 10 to minus six in
this example you're pointing it actually
I wasn't thinking that but this is I see
so you're saying that in this case there
will be nine digits no but the whole
point is you can't have trailing zeros
so you have no choice right because
because what you could never get is a
situation where there are trailing zeros
in the main number you can yes for
example there if you go further down in
that column you have many trading
seriously I think that's fine because if
you are specifying a number exactly but
this is a rare case because most of the
time this wouldn't be correct right most
of the time the error would already be
creeping in before you get to the
trailing zeros well if they used to
specify that the error is so small I
know but that's a weird case because
that's not going to come from a physical
measurement because physics doesn't have
a preference for you know powers of ten
yes but I think it's a problem in the
input I mean if we get exactly there the
input that we have there I think we have
to show this I agree yeah I agree but
what I'm saying is I think that's a rare
case where there you know but I'm saying
there are cases where
yeah okay well so my statement is okay
so how would we avoid this case what do
we do to avoid that case in this
particular case we can say it's point 1
2 whatever and we just add more zeroes
here right yes that case we could we
could say zero point 1 2 3 4 5 7 and in
parentheses 23 well all we could just
have more zeroes or we could just say
plus minus point zero zero zero zero two
three yes we can do that this way see
the point 1 plus minus zero point or
seriously right so the question is is it
worse to have more zeroes or to go to
the list notation yes that's yet another
thing for example in this paper we were
talking about the measurement of the
gravitational constant they have things
like like ten point two and then in
parentheses one point seven so the
decimal point gets into that parenthesis
which is quite interesting that's crazy
that's very hard to interpret yeah I
understand those cases as well okay
look I don't like this case I don't like
saying times 10 to the minus 1 right so
ok so we've got two choices if we kind
of avoid things below 10 to the 6 we've
got two choices we have more zeroes
where we go to paren notation okay I
guess we should probably go to paren
notation okay so in other words if there
are more than three zeroes in the error
we go to paren notation but that would
be my suggestion for the default okay
okay okay now meanwhile a round form
would parameterize these things that
correct yes that's idea though I mean
there are still so many things to
parameterize that I'm trying to classify
like for example what is the thracian
they have examples further down on the
Thresher
but before we go there so there is this
asymmetric case in which we have the
same problem let's look at this case hey
why is there a point where is there a
decimal point after the for the oh it's
right yeah that's right
I mean it will be nicer if that was one
plus or minus four wouldn't be without
the decimal points I find it a bit
inconsistent with the rest because these
are all approximate numbers yeah all
right okay okay I provisionally agree
with you okay so this is the same
situation as before but because it's
about the threshold of 35 it shows only
one digit but the Proms are basically
someone yeah I don't think there's a
huge problem with any of these okay now
these cases here which I don't like
exactly yeah so that should be zero
point one yes
okay so then the pragmatic case here is
when we go to the asymmetric case and we
try to do the parentheses notation which
I must have made I have nursing then it
becomes weird when we have errors of
different number of digits because it is
difficult to align so in this case we
have this plus four minus 23 meaning I
think looks magnificent I mean I think
that what does this actually mean
exactly so it is therefore with the
first digit or the second digit of the
of that pair well is it 40 or is it for
it the truth is that it is 40 okay so
why don't we write 14 why don't we why
don't we make the number of digits agree
well perhaps we have to do that but
there in general is if you go above 35
then you show only one day and I was
trying to keep that rule but perhaps
here they don't think that's gonna work
because I wouldn't know whether that's
plus minus 4 right I just don't think
that's knowable I think if you've got
two digits here you've got to say plus
40 minus 23 okay okay yeah we can say in
this case we don't follow the rule of
number of digits so let's look at this
case here so this case here that's
absolutely fine that's hunky-dory it
doesn't
because that's not the sign right it's
only in this case that we have to deal
with that right but if we insisting
having the same number of digits I will
also have the same number of digits in
the other case perhaps focuses on here
yes
there's no I don't agree I don't agree
because you don't know that the the
trailing digit there I wouldn't do it I
don't think it matters I think this is
fine because the in the case of a very
very asymmetric error which could happen
you know I mean this is gonna get exotic
in the case of a very asymmetric error
down here but that's okay because it is
an exotic case okay okay so then when we
have this stand out plus/minus
asymmetric we keep their separate number
of digits but here we align them yeah
okay that's what I'm suggesting yes
George our livestream is saying he was
lucky to get four significant digits in
experiments he did yeah um yeah anyway
supporting my point of view that this is
an exotic case but but again the thing
that we're gonna see in the wild is
there's people generating this from
let's say a number theory experiment or
something you know generating it from
from data that they are producing you
know computationally and I think then
the N squared argument holds so I'm good
with this this is this is wonderful
actually I mean this is very nice and
don't forget to put in some of these
tables in the in the documentation
sure yes yes we'll probably have a
tutorial dedicated to explaining t-tops
yeah well nowadays those are called tech
notes okay so in terms of so here this
last part right now there is an internal
parameter this inserted a wrong number
which is 35.5 which determines when we
have two digits or one date
the upper and so this is a way of
changing two for example 255 and then
the error appear with three digits
yeah I understand so you know to my mind
you should just get every parameter you
know about put them in an association
and put them in there you know and put
them as as options to a round form but I
don't think that's essential for the
first release okay I mean frankly I
think people are gonna like these
defaults very much and I think it's
wonderful by the way negative numbers to
work in a nice way right with everything
we're doing yeah they just work you just
put my outside that yes/no Pro and
complex numbers complex numbers work as
well so basically what they are doing is
that they are is like boxes and they're
real part of the arrow goes with every
or part and the imaginary part was okay
so in fact though like in the particle
data book as I recall there are error
ellipses in the complex plane and those
we cannot represent well those would be
beam correlations those are cases in
which we have correlations I see if the
ellipse is tilted it means there's
correlation between errors but if the
ellipse isn't tilted getting plus minus
for the real imaginary parts would be a
rectangle not an ellipse right if it
just say independently plus minus you
know plus minus one in the imaginary
part plus minus two in the real part
that is a rectangle in the complex plane
not an ellipse yes that's the
interpretation yes yes it's a product of
one distribution times the other
distribution yeah right but now in fact
when people give errors in the complex
plane they do mean that don't they the
rectangle
even though often in the actual
measurement you know they've got some
phase angle or some such other thing
which is uncertain so they're really in
a polar coordinate situation but they're
not admitting that hey it is oh I see
well so we can't represent that
perfectly but that's life you can
represent it if you put in the
correlation stuff is that true can you
represent an ellipse an error ellipse
and even an unfiltered error ellipse
with correlations yeah because you can
get the second-order yes yes but now it
wouldn't be a complex number it will be
a pair of tennis numbers so yeah I
understand a pair of numbers with a
second order correlation thing that was
given right yeah that would be a nice
example to get by the way yeah polar
coordinate conversion all right I think
we're done with this looks wonderful and
more stuff to be gone over for the
around stuff it really looks extremely
nice okay go ahead
yes so now we have is our standard
collection of suggestions of reasons is
Tian's right so this has been suggested
the number of times this is stupid
this makes student think that's stupid
that's unreadable that that was
precisely the type of thing that well
you mean six hours five minutes and 24
seconds and things I mean I suppose that
might be useful possibly but the issue
here is should absolute timing give back
something with units right that's the
basic question yeah and I think the
answer is yes you probably should be
able to get that I think it's obvious
the absolute timing was designed thirty
years before we had units I think
returned and number multiplied by a
single second oh yeah that was
horrifying well if it did that maybe we
can get away with having it returned I
don't know I'm sure there are many
comparisons in the code with right I
wouldn't do it by default but the idea
is to have something that forces the
return like an optional another argument
I don't find it sentimental but it's
true that it has been suggested a few
times right
well the real thing is people wanted to
return that way by default and we can't
do that with the current function with
its current name yes that I think it
would be quite dangerous to change the I
mean the truth is that the name timing
for example or absolute timing is it's
kind of a wrong name because it's
returning the expression as well I mean
you know it would be better in modern
naming conventions it would be something
like you know evaluate timing evaluate
time to some such other thing would
actually be the correct form because it
is like you know REM of you know 3 + I
or something
it's the combination it's a combination
function it both evaluates and gives
timing I said to me it's a bit superior
function yes right though given the
order perhaps it should be time to
evaluate yeah except that might mean
something at different I mean timing
evaluate of course evaluate is kind of
the non function in many ways it's a
function whose name is never mentioned
because it doesn't term
time to see the problem of time to
evaluate is it suggests that it is well
this is I mean it's kind of buddy time
to evaluate
I mean we've now got also repeated time
and what does repeated timing do it's
basically same the same thing and it
doesn't have units either right but it
does have extra arguments yes the number
of times you want to repeat well no it's
actually specified at least one second
should be used to time the operation
does repeat evaluation for at least that
number of seconds that's why I was
thinking that perhaps an option is less
jarring here well I agree but by the
time you've got an option you could just
multiply it by you know you could just
say you know perfectly well say quantity
of tight oh no you couldn't because it's
a mess it's the first time that's why I
added the Muppet right well so what are
you saying you're saying there will be
an option called timing units arrow and
then you could either give automatic
which would do now or none would you
give a number or dimensionless perhaps
unit yeah I think the mission is you
need would be that different well okay I
don't think this is totally crazy I mean
it's a little bit in the blarf category
having separate functions has to fill in
that we have three already so we have I
know I know I know
horrible so Nick what do you think about
this yeah I think timing units gives us
flexibility you know there's always the
potential that in the future if we
really want to for
it is a default we could change the
option value well notice that we have
things like this where that might also
be useful right
yeah well ping time returns a quantity
by D fight I know that I know that maybe
it shouldn't necessarily I mean in other
words we could do timing units ping
times timing units would be by default
automatic like but you could if you
wanted to set it to none and then it
would just give numbers you may be
useful it's always milliseconds here
probably not it's probably whatever it's
probably automatic isn't it
I'm not sure how Fahim set it up okay
but I guess I mean if this was I think
that what we have to do is this would
have the unit convert to seconds right
but I mean it could be nice to have the
option here as well and then by default
we preserve what we do right now but if
so exactly right if they want seconds
well okay so that okay no what I mean is
if they say none timing units to none
see look there's two different cases
there's convert to seconds and given
once it is in seconds and convert to
seconds and give the quantity magnitude
right latest if you say units are none
then what else the actual value well
none would probably be the SI unit of
time which is seconds yeah yeah even if
even in the details for ping time you
know if you're setting update intervals
or time constraints it assumes they're
in seconds so I think it again makes
sense to use seconds as the device we
should we should let's imagine that
timing units is something which we put
into all these places and the defaults
are different between timing and ping
time but otherwise it will work the same
mm-hmm reasonable I think so
okay let's move on
um I suspect this is gonna be a longer
discussion um let's let's talk about the
synonyms and antonyms function which i
think is very straightforward yeah I was
I think synonyms and antonyms is pretty
straightforward I did notice that
related to at least in what we haven't
word data related to synonyms antonyms
and definitions we also have terms
called broader terms and narrower terms
I don't know I think your growth names I
wanted to do is similar that better than
hyper names and hypo names right yeah
and which is which nobody would
understand um without well you know if
you happen to know Greek you can decode
them tie things I guess I'm just not
sure that broader terms without any
additional techno wouldn't work that's
not that's not a useable thing for I
mean then we would have to call it hyper
names if we were to do that I have to
say I think a lot of those are not very
useful okay so then the way this will
work I assume so don't these words also
have entities associated with them yes
they're both word entities and there are
going to be word sense entities so the
idea would be that you know okay so this
is an entity to entity creature but if
you give a string it's a string to
string creature I think so yeah makes
sense to me okay I think that's good
antonyms and synonyms why not mm-hmm I
mean what one means by synonym is a
total mess right right I mean in other
words in the space of word meanings a
word you know in in meaning space a word
represents some block and meaning space
many words have a you know if you say
content versus happy right those clearly
have an overlap of meaning but they are
not the same word right
languages very rarely have two words for
exactly the same thing mm-hmm
some contextual difference implied
context right I mean like this these are
a good example I mean okay good
bad evil those that's fairly nice but
these good dependable effective okay
terrific
you know but those are very different
word meanings and I think in you know in
some time in the future we will have
some notion of you know practice we
already do have a meaning space idea so
there is a possibility if we are to be a
little bit more exotic about it there is
a conceivable possibility that there's a
synonym distance that we could define
for making sense note that we are
eliminating part of that information
with this use of last there so what the
data good synonyms is reporting more
information graphic evaluated
we going to have those blue boxes agree
with our other blue boxes so you know
well okay so synonyms by the way
obviously needs a language option yeah
and I know Ben and Alan and the rest of
the word team have been working on
standardizing and updating the
dictionary sets we're looking at so that
they're common across same language is
available everywhere etc yep which will
plug in here yep I mean you know this is
all a fake at some level I mean synonyms
are a fake idea um but I do like the
idea of having some yeah I mean if you
give the word sense entity then clearly
you're going to have a lot more
opportunity to get it right in a case
like this um yeah yeah someone on our
livestream is suggesting Rimes and Nia
rhymes yeah but we certainly have code
to do that I mean we have you know the
other kinds of things we have like this
that we could expose our anagrams rhymes
other stuff like that I mean ultimately
anagrams or word is a cool thing to have
and we certainly could have it yeah I
mean homonyms always a little tricky
because there's so many different types
of rhyming to I mean we I don't think we
really need a parameterised homonyms
function that's it depends on your
accent you know note in Canadian might
rhyme with boat or something but doesn't
an American yeah um
right yes after our live stream is
suggesting a distance metric like the
glove distance metric I agree that was
what I was thinking of although I don't
think that will work for a while I mean
I think that we have you know I mean if
we were to do the experiment right now
of what
words are near so I mean if we make a
nearest function from word list using a
distance function that is let's see we
want net model of glove whatever it is
right is this gonna work
AG is this crazy or is this does this
give sisters let's do the right thing
the if I give that a word well in my
case I mean the basically the point is
this notion of a of a distance function
you know a synonym distance is I think a
semi reasonable thing we don't have a
semantic distance function yet do we not
that I'm aware of anything some sort of
implicit in some of the stuff ETA did
but that's not the same as an explicit
one right well I think we avoided it
because it's kind of silly and
meaningless because you know it's like
but this is what we're using okay great
so we say percent fourteen of okay so we
actually have to make a distance
function that uses this if we say good
here it's just going to give a vector of
length 100 right yeah so so so we can
make a distance function out of this and
that will be an interesting thing will
be a nice thing to compare our good
exercise for somebody to compare our
synonyms function with what you would
get from the glove out to some distance
that's a fun experiment I wouldn't mind
trying that myself um in fact I will
the um yeah right people are suggesting
on the livestream various kinds of
grammar rules and so on yeah we we know
there are other things one can do here I
mean the problem is it gets very you
have to start worrying about dialects
and all kinds of horrendous things I
mean we're just now putting in the
spelling dictionaries with you know
British versus American and yeah it's
it's really complicated I think I think
though that they just for the plane
let's get an answer in let's get a
synonym that's useful there will be some
nice exploratory things yes somebody's
asking for synonyms for multi-word
phrases boy you guys asked for
everything I should point out that the
American version of that thing is always
American versus British never British
versus American did I say it the wrong
way around Iran I'm sure um okay look I
think for right now just the simple
synonyms and antonyms functions seemed
fine to me
the question of synonyms for multi-word
phrases we can ask Alan and team what
what is happening with that but
complicated mess okay
can-can I am let's let's look at these
comments on subset map and then I want
to very briefly go to the phone number
stuff oh boy okay so is there a bottom
line here to watch some okay subset
sort okay yes that would be beautiful
position of data series
that's interesting so the all case of
subset map okay it's used with the
proposed syntax and the in-place form
what is the in-place form I JEA okay so
what would you do and I'm sorry the
in-place form here would say what
be saying apply that function to so you
say list of all comma 3 at equals F
would be equivalent to subset map list
equals subset map of list comma
of F comma list comma all comma three
that right
I'll write that out so you're saying
here list all comma three
at equals f is equivalent to list equals
subset Matt of F comma list comer all
comma 3 is that right right though
yes something like that I may be
confused between again party specs and
struck this back because all this list
Ultima 3 is is a straight but yes he was
he was looking for something that um
by the way someone on our livestream is
pointing out how great our language is
for education and how language learning
is part of that and I thoroughly agree
with that which is why I've been pushing
a bunch of these language things it does
occur to me do we have something which
checks whether a word is spelled
correctly
we have dictionary word Q which we
originally were thinking about calling
it correctly spelled Q but it's awkward
and we have spelling correction list
which gives a list of possible
Corrections and returns none if it is
what is in the front end is it something
that is not actually exposed
functionality so we used the same
library it's basically the the kernel is
calling the same thing that the front
end is okay they're not you know the
front the front end is not using a
kernel and the kernel is not calling the
front end directly they're both calling
into the same utilities okay but an hour
spelling dictionary which we add to
practically every day is flowing through
to all of those places right yes and and
why did this do does this go out is this
a certain number of words or does this
car to a certain distance so we used the
same default distance parameters that
are given by the library we don't
currently have a visitor fairly stupid
in my opinion I mean what it's doing
here um and I don't know why it's got
proper names well I guess it should have
proper names but but that's a so there's
no parameter here that says give me 20
spelling correction words there isn't at
the moment but we could certainly
include there okay might be worth doing
that I mean it may be worth looking at
what the and does the spelling
correction list work for does it work
for languages other than English yeah
yeah we plug into the same magnificent
okay and it works for multi-word as well
right yes okay all right I'm sorry back
to this subset map thing okay so what is
the okay let's use of the proposed
syntax I think this is less important he
wanted to be able to act on several
columns at the same time he was
wondering how to do that but to me the
nice thing the most important thing is
having a different look at functionality
from this set versus part point of view
because for the name yes then I think
the name is honestly I'm not completely
sold on the name now because as we start
seeing more and more uses of this thing
the last names you suggested was some
map across okay
how do people feel
about that name I still refer subset map
but right okay so so wait a second so
let's let's go back up here so multiple
columns for each column instead of a
list of pairs right so that yes all 2
comma 3 is that a list of all pairs or
two columns so it's a transpose of one
another
well wait a second wait I said what are
you saying so this one here is that
right yes so he suggests in another
notation to avoid the ambiguity with all
least two three which would be the list
of pairs well he he wants to act on two
columns I'm totally confused here so so
we have subset map of F and let's say F
is a matrix axonometric says so right so
here comma 2 yes that's the least what
that's the second column of change list
2 matrix okay but what is this - now it
will take the second column F we get
that column it will return another
column and we'll put it back
so imagine f is accumulate okay okay
okay so I get it gets one gulp of a
whole column right now what he's saying
is that if we use all comma two three it
will get a list of terms but he wants us
to pass what kind of women what kind of
it will get a list of pairs from column
2 and from column 3 is that correct
right okay so the question is how can
you operate with F being fed the whole
of column 2 and the whole of column 3
exactly and is there a proposal for how
to do that I mean in other words one way
to do that I would have thought would be
to just say all comma two all comma 3 am
I mistaken well that something was on
support' right now in this extract spec
but we could pirate code we could he was
actually suggesting something similar
but with a specific head called but list
here I understand
I mean decorating that just like we have
things like span and so on I would say
those decorations have been only mildly
successful well as long as there is no
ambiguity this is fine but we have to
check that it doesn't lead to anemia T
let's check
ethan black 86 on our live stream is
suggesting map into as a possible name
for this creature and someone else is
saying that all to all three is
ambiguous why I don't think so I think
that represents a column um what do we
think about map into
so map at says do it at these points and
I don't think into is quite right if
it's going to be a preposition like that
it's got to be something like a cross
yeah I see and singer gross works better
here but yeah and these come back
eighty-six is saying Matt column would
be nice syntactic sugar I agree with
that I am still pushing for a map column
or column map the problem is where does
it end
you know right and we still have the
issue of whether it's mapping on the
elements of the columns or on the
colonies itself okay so the the
ambiguity comment is if we take
something like this I don't know what
does that mean subset map of F I would
interpret that as two positions
extracting two positions or four matrix
okay but why isn't that okay so that's
saying that subset map has to be folded
in order to do small Teeple applications
of F so what I'm saying if you want some
subset map is just doing a one-shot no
but I think F should always get all the
elements at the same time and then it
returns something of the same structure
and puts them back
yeah I understand where's map at can zap
you know can insert F in multiple places
it's what this is saying is it can only
insert F in one place right the same
places it extracted right which makes
the word map a little bit confusing it's
an extension of month well it's a it's a
D extension of map in some ways because
map typically puts F in too many places
in an expression where this is putting
it into one place in an expression if
I'm not mistaken so this is a single
application of F yes yes I mean it's
almost no it's it's I mean this idea of
a single application of F I mean it's
it's kind of more like it's not like
curry because curry takes arguments what
this is doing is it's it's a play it's
not applied because apply fact yes so
whisper blazing head yeah all right okay
and you might argue that map at I mean
the problem with map a versus map at can
have a list of you know can have a list
of positions to map at whereas this what
this is doing is it's taking a single
block of data well it's taking two
blocks of data it's always - right right
- well because it's doing its it's a
list of supports I see I see an F is
applied to the subplot parts and it
always has to give a result that is the
same shape as those sub parts that then
will
you know map in place the problem with
that is it suggests that it's in place
in the sense of memory yeah and a sense
map is always in place so that's a silly
name
well subset map it's not sounding
horrible still subpart map don't think
it really helps anything um I don't
think it's a perfect name transform part
as the name suggested here
okay so the question of whether this
case here what does this case here mean
it will extract matrix of 1/2 and matrix
of 3/4 put them in a list apply F and
then put the Mac right to single
elements apply after them to a list of
them yeah to a list of those right but
it's not an apply it's a map right
exactly it's a construct of F comma the
list of elements right well fair enough
I think that getting um yeah I mean I
think nothing is dead yet yeah now in
terms of this this former I don't know
let's you know what I mean this is
amusing but but I mean if what that
would imply is you know that's an append
to so this will be a subset map to left
and we don't know what's that yes
exactly it's a to version of subsets map
but we don't even have you know a map to
we've never needed a map to right or a
map at two so I think I think the you
know it's just not that hard to say list
equals this this doesn't seem to me that
it helps anything to have a totally
funky syntax okay so okay so I think we
should keep going with subset map unless
we can come up I mean so far that name
is the least bad name that I've seen for
this every all right I'm afraid we let's
just take a very very very quick look I
know I have to go to another meeting
here um
let's see by the way did we sort out and
play not for this meeting the business
about smiles strings and the chemical
name business that's probably for not
for this meeting
I know if Sushma knows about that okay
all right you know we are going to end
up having to have these rappers and they
are part of the world and I don't see
why we shouldn't have them so phone
number and physical address seemed
seemed good to me personally was a there
was a bit more worried because we have
person data in and I was wondering
what's the deal right you're right it's
not person it's the name of a person
right because phone numbers and physical
addresses is something that may change
even in time but person has some more
historical sense to it well yes the
person in the current state of the world
a person is a very distinct entity that
you know lives a certain time and
there's no cloning of it and so on right
I mean if if we were describing
personhood for what like I don't know
what some worms where you can split the
worm in two then we would have a
different story but since that isn't the
situation with humans right we have
there's a different notion of person
then right so I agree with you this is
person name and in fact person you know
even if they change their name they are
still the same person they have a
different person name right yeah I agree
but I mean the point of our person name
is that it matters whether it's Smith
comma John you know professor doctor dr.
John Smith etc etc so I agree with that
it should be person name but now in
terms of things like phone number yeah I
mean I agree that there would be
we should have that representation and I
suspect we would be able to still change
what interpreter returns for this case
no we don't want to do entity phone
number because it's the same thing as
with molecules right there are you know
there are a indefinitely constructible
number of phone numbers isn't right and
it's more like integers than it is like
like cities where I mean okay all right
I admit philosophically there's sort of
a you know you could construct an
indefinite number of of cities too but
but there are a certain set of you know
legally incorporated cities or something
in the world some so I think I think
yeah it's the right thing is to have a
wrapper and exactly what the form of the
wrapper is you know that I think there's
a nice canonical representation where we
basically have the full phone number
string we have like the area code broken
out the country code broken out and so
on okay this is every meeting I don't
know who's gonna lead that um Nick is
this going to be in your area or who's
going to be dealing with the actual
output here and I think Carlo B had been
the person working on a phone number
pausing if I remember correctly and I
suspect he has Finian's about that I
know in terms of the you know the person
data thing which is the thing we really
need to the person name thing that's
something we really need to solve for
all kinds of reasons for the ELP project
and so on um physical address is another
can of worms I mean I don't know whether
you know physical address in in you know
having a good representation of that in
like a country like Japan seems
complicated I don't know is anybody know
the you know like like in you know a
typical form will say you know Street
you know what is your street address
what's your you know typical American
style form will say Street city state
country type thing what does it do in
Japan for example
when you typically have a you know a
similar setup you have building number
you'll have ward within the city city
prefecture etc the hierarchical so so in
the case of so in all of these cases
once thinking about it it's a
hierarchical specification it's just
that in the in the in the US case it's
yeah okay fine
you have a one-parameter family in the
case of a street whereas in the case of
what you're describing there it's a two
dimensional blob of of area is that
right generally I mean the you still
have street addresses but you tend to
break them down into extra hierarchies I
mean I know there are some places like
Mongolia where it's harder because you
don't generally have the same notion of
a physical address but how that's
handled I don't I'm not really familiar
with right um
yeah right no I know that's what the the
that that crazy idea of having the you
know the three words that represent a
location on the earth oh yeah Mongolia
for so long I know there was really
popular over that's just some media
nonsense but you know yeah I dunno I
mean there are funky things like the
case in I think Phnom Penh in Cambodia
right where the street numbers are
random because they were they were based
on when you know the historical order in
which things were occupied rather than
the rather than their position on the
street mmm um but I don't we're not we
don't have to worry about that because
we're not dealing with proximity that
way with that that's just for the geo
coder we have to worry about that um so
okay fair enough
well I think we need let's pick this up
at a different time do other people need
to be in the meeting to discuss person
name and so I suspect they do I think
Alan for probably hell and at least yeah
and I think Carlo should be there for
the phone number one and that's an Cisco
for physical address because he has work
with an eminent him okay great
fine so can we and then let's also
[Music]
we should probably add Daniel Bigham
it's ok um since he's a consumer of this
stuff ok
last point here South China is saying
there should be an operator form of
subset map don't we have an operator
form proposed for subset map yes yes did
two arguments then the function and the
positions yeah okay fine let's look
that's the correct thing yeah there it
is
okay well I think that's all we have
time for right now um thanks thanks
everyone here and thanks to a live
stream lots of good comments today
thanks a lot see you all soon
thank you